back to your question about how to build
a reading habit it's that you need to be
very honest with yourself about what
you're interested in and starting from
and having an idea of what what piques
your interest I think if you can choose
topics and books and authors that are
focused on those interests that is the
best way to build a reading habit
because then it does not feel like a
chore it really just feels like a
leisure activity
Jim melanne how are you my friend
pleasant doing well enjoying my lockdown
and style here and my sweatpants in my
sweatshirt doing well it's gotta be out
enjoying that new mustache it's not new
unfortunately it's all I can grow that
is that's a serious - going on there
yeah so I like to tell people I'm a
little follically challenged so I like
to overcompensate with the mustache
because it grabs people's attention and
then it veers the attention away from
the fact that's all I can grow so focus
on your strengths I get it my peacocking
but only above the lip yes guys eyes up
here up top up top so your Instagram
account which is what a lot of people
listening might know you for get better
with it how would you describe what is
that what is get better with books yeah
better wood books is currently the
fastest growing Instagram page focused
specifically on self-help personal
development business related books it
really just started as a creative
endeavor where I could combine my my
interest in photography am i interested
in reading and have have something to do
about some of my day job but I've been
doing it for almost two years now may
15th will be my two year anniversary
running the page and I think as of today
I'm a little over 85,000 followers so
I'm a little dumbfounded of how quickly
it's grown and the fact that people
enjoy seeing content specifically around
books but it's been a fun fun journey so
far why do you think it is popular I
think it for a couple different reasons
number one it speaks to the attitudes of
a lot of people out there not just in
the US but internationally speaking if
you take a look at some of the the data
that I get to pull from the Instagram
account I'd say a third of my audiences
us-based
what's the Third's in Europe I'd say
overwhelming majority people are from
India and I think it speaks to the
psychographic of certain people who are
just focused on developing themselves as
an individual right they use books as a
tool to to better themselves and I think
it speaks to a lot of people who love
reading but more importantly improving
themselves yeah sure how many books have
you read do you know
I haven't kept count unfortunately a lot
of these people that's religious on good
Goodreads or anything yeah no I don't
keep an active Goodreads account but if
I would estimate how many books that
I've read in my lifetime I'd say
probably are like 150 160 books and I
think last year in the year before were
really the first two years that I've
actually kept track of how many books
I've read so last year I think I got up
to fifty for the course of the year in
the year before I was at you know little
over 30 and it's important to also
acknowledge the fact that these these
metrics like how many books that you've
read or how quickly you read books I
think that can be a distraction for a
lot of people right they Stasi book says
is almost like a vanity metric like how
many books have you read in total and I
have this conversation with a lot of
other book Instagram accounts that I see
as cohorts and we we almost see that as
a disdain right like if you read a
hundred books in a month but you don't
you don't retain anything right is it is
it worth it or are you just using that
metric to and as a feather in your cap
if you will yeah well I mean in this age
now this burgeoning underground movement
the the new a forests that are coming
out that like the maxim you know this
show is called modern wisdom I am part
of the [ __ ] problem as far as that is
concerned you know like but there is
there is like a um there is an ongoing
subculture now of people that I think a
kind of repatriating wisdom you know
like kind of falling back into the the
timeless understandings of the
principles that we should live our life
by trying to incur and cover what we are
who we are why we like the things we
like why the world operates the way that
it does and you're totally correct as
well that by reading a lot or by saying
that you read a lot you never know if
someone actually does read two books a
week over by either saying that you read
a lot or reading a lot you um you get to
have the the proxy you get to have the
veneer of looking wise whilst not ever
having to deploy
any wisdom young man hits it's an
interesting juxtaposition of the two
right because you have the the short
morsels of wisdom that you get from
social media and you overlay that with
the long-form content which is
inherently in books right and comparing
the two on the surface it almost seems
like it doesn't mix right like how can
you semis a three hundred and four
hundred page book like twelve rules of
life right Jordan Peterson for example
right and you see he's very popular in
social media but it's hard to distill
wisdom in a book like that in you know
it an Instagram post right so it's an
interesting dynamic between the two but
I also think it's a good opportunity to
just expose more people to the benefits
of reading because there are a lot of
people who come to my account and they
ask me questions they're like hey bro
like I just started reading a couple
months ago like what books would you
recommend to a beginner and for someone
like me I don't see myself as an expert
like I'm just someone who likes reading
and I have an Instagram page like
apparently that makes me an expert but
at the end of the day there are a
handful of books that I always go to as
hey you're new to reading here a few
that you should consider reading so I
guess I am I'm somewhat of a book expert
if you follow my Instagram page I get it
yeah we are going to get into that we've
got all of the recommendations and that
will be coming in a little bit but first
why I wanted to ask was what are the
common mistakes that you think people
make or perhaps the ones that you made
as well when building a reading habit
because before you read the books that
you might recommend to people it has to
be a habit to be able to actually get
through them absolutely I think the
first mistake that I come across from a
lot of new people is they they feel like
you have to finish a book right if you
come across a book that was highly
recommended and maybe you just don't
find it interesting it doesn't pick your
your your nerve or it doesn't strike
your nerve at all you feel like you are
forced to finish it from end to end
right and that's one of the biggest
mistakes because if if you are not
interested in a book it's gonna feel
like a chore right it's not going to
feel like something that you're you're
actually getting a lot of benefit from
so if you don't like a book please do
not waste the time I mean it's kind of
like
a movie if you're sitting at home
watching Netflix and you come across a
movie in 10-15 minutes into it you just
don't like it you don't sit through the
next 4550 minutes right so it shouldn't
be anything different than then reading
a book and I think a lot of people just
have this attitude that I have to finish
a book yeah it just sunk cost fallacy is
it that people see it as a badge of
honor to get through a difficult book
sometimes it there there's a lot of
public relations when it comes to hey
I'm gonna read this book and I need to
save face by by actually finishing it
from start to end we're having a little
bit of self-confidence to say like you
know I did not like this book I wanted
to put it down and I wanted to start
something that I'm interested so it's
it's really just being comfortable with
yourself to say yeah not digging this
I'm gonna put it down yeah it's the
other thing is well this came from Kemal
rava can't conversation I had with him
and he said 90% of self development
books should have been sorry 50% of
self-development books should have been
an article and 49 percent should have
been a tweet yeah absolutely one percent
which actually needed 300 pages 400
pages to pad out the concept John
Pearson's is a good example or anything
by Talib like he's not really it's not
about that the one thing you know him
like digital minimalism by kalampore
shouldn't mean an article now don't get
me wrong you can have this is a strategy
and it's a workbook at a course or
whatever that you wanna sit on the side
mmm but that could have been long blog
post right and if you if you read a lot
more books you come to that realization
that most of the books that you read
they're either similar and a lot of ways
or just like he said they probably could
have been summarized in a page or maybe
in a YouTube video and I think one of
the books in hot-hot take here and I
actually get a lot of flack on Instagram
for this is there's a book start with Y
by simon Sinek
it's widely popular in the book sir
Graham fear and people say this is a
life-changing book and I came across the
book and I said this is mildly
interesting but I think it's very
superficial I think it's
very redundant and I wasn't a huge
venomous and I was I've been very public
about my stance about that book
and that just goes to your to your fact
that not not everyone has the same
opinions on popular books and I think
it's very important to to be upfront
with yourself to not not pretend that
you enjoy a book just because it's
popular but I Mets it's your point about
these books that could be that may be
summarized in a blog post yeah that's
that's that was one of I think there's a
four or five minute video on on YouTube
about that to start with why concept by
him talking in a TED talk so anyone who
has not read start with why I would say
just check out his YouTube video and if
it's if it's something that piques your
interest a little bit more than maybe
pick up the book so hopefully I saved
you a couple days at reading that yeah
yeah for sure
um mark Monson this sort of odd liking
just didn't get him on just I'm like
okay mark you keep swearing cool
like that's where you draw the line you
just kept on swearing I was like I get
it like this is a book that's about
swearing and I mean like that was it but
then models by him how they were
tracking him in through honesty he's
amazing and that couldn't have been a
tweet that couldn't have been in a blog
post or an article any guys listening
who want to kind of up their game
especially as we're about to re-release
ourselves back out of lockdown models by
Mark Manson is like the the pickup
artistry book for people that don't want
to be CD pickup artists write about how
to maximize your confidence how to
actually be a fuller version of you and
the basics of attraction between men and
women and I think it's great but so long
I was like alright mark cool and I think
it's it's important to understand that
you don't again you don't have to like
every book that's popular on social
media and when it comes to enjoying
books I think a lot of it has to do with
not only the content but the the
author's writing style right you can
come across an author that you just
truly vibe with how they write in
regardless of what the content is you
could sit down for hours and hours at a
day just because of the writing style
it's so enjoyable right there's some of
those authors for you a number one that
comes to mind is David Brooks he wrote a
couple books the road to character which
is easily in my top
ten books it's it's more that self-help
book but it's more emphasizing true
virtues right like living with it with
chivalry and just living with honor and
as opposed to focusing on the external
virtues right of Commerce and and status
right it's more important to be upfront
with yourself and what do you truly
believe in so the road to character
David Brooks I think he was a columnist
in New York Times so just a trim and
just write or someone that I truly enjoy
but another writer that's I'm starting
to absolutely adore Robin Sharma I'm
sure you guys are all film familiar with
the five a.m. Club this this little okay
dandy right here the five M Club so I
this was one of the books that I came
across just because I saw it all over
Instagram right like I'm I'm human too I
pick up my my future reads just based
off what I'm seeing on social media and
social proof right if people are raving
about a book there's probably a reason
why it's so popular and that was one of
the books and so far I'm I just started
reading it a couple days ago there's
there's a certain storytelling vibe
right and you you come across a writer
who can easily detail certain intricate
parts of a relationship or certain
nuances and body language right when you
can read how a writer is detailing a
whole scene and an atmosphere and a mood
you you almost forget that you're
reading right like you're it's almost
like you're watching a movie and it's
those types of books that are more of
story focus as opposed to you know that
the point by point by point self-help
books it sometimes aren't as enjoyable
to read these are or type that the
stories that I've definitely been a lot
more accustomed to recently I love that
okay so we know that you're not supposed
to think that you need to finish a book
done is a bad habit what else before we
go into how to build a reading habit are
there any other like common errors that
people are making when they when they
start out I think another common error
is just focusing on the metrics right
you you get in this idea that I have to
read 50 books this year or I have to
read two books a month because the
latest business site or calm article
said the most successful people are
reading X amount of books per month and
I think I'm successful so I need to live
up to that metric right so I think
beholding yourself to some of those
external metrics and I call vanity
metrics it almost lose you lose sight of
why you're reading in the first place
right like you at the end of the day you
want to pick up a book to either learn
something new to expand your wisdom
expand your perspective and if those
ideas those thoughts are clouded by
simply I need to finish this book faster
so I can get to my next one it's
counterproductive so I think just
exactly so I think it's more important
to just remind yourself why you're
reading in the first place as opposed to
like you just mentioned like having
having like a tally mark next to how
many books you read just for vanity
purposes yeah I think I love the analogy
and it's not one that I've thought of
before about if you were watching a bad
movie no I'm ruthless on Netflix man so
Ruth I'm straight out of there I'm
pressing the back button telling
everyone I'm sat with it's absolutely
terrible so and yet I need to say you
know with books I think I'm Ryan holiday
when he reversed interviewed Tim Ferriss
on the Tim Ferriss show they talked
about breeding quite a lot might be an
interesting one for you and uh I think
his heuristic is if you are whatever a
hundred pages minus your age into a book
and you haven't wanted to send a photo
of one of the passages to a body going
like oh my god dude like you've got to
see this that like that that's the rule
that he uses and I really let's just say
I really like that and I thinking back
to some of the stuff that's got me
recently so Robert writes the moral
animal just plain took my head off I was
like two pages in and then just on my
highlights on Kindle like just the whole
page was highlighted hey Ryan you know
what you're in a room and I get it so
yeah you you you totally correct having
the courage to put a book down despite
what every essays respite whether it's
supposed to be cool despite whether you
loved their first book I loved Mark
Ronson's models just a lot of not given
a [ __ ] couldn't give a [ __ ]
so I always wait to say that okay so
that's how we don't build a rating habit
how do we build a reading habit why do
we stop it starts with just being
upfront about what your interests are
right so if you you take a look at the
get better with books page there's an
obvious emphasis on self-help personal
development business right
maybe personal finance books it's its
unintended but I've catered towards a
specific demographic of you know
eighteen to thirty four males right
college educated males people who either
have a steady career or either getting
into the workforce and are interested in
in upping their game right that's that's
again unintended about how I started and
where I'm cater to but at the end of the
day that's that's not the interest of
everybody out there right there are
people who follow my page that are you
know at the 45 year old woman from from
Pakistan right and she may not give a
[ __ ] about you know what Dave Ramsey
says about Total Money Makeover is right
and that's okay right and and back to
your question about how to build a
reading habit it's that you need to be
very honest with yourself about what
you're interested in in starting from
you know having an idea of what what
piques your interest I think if you can
choose topics and books and authors that
are focused on those interests that is
the best way to build a reading habit
because then it does not feel like a
chore it really just feels like a
leisure activity and once you can start
building up a couple books specifically
focusing on a topic that you're
interested in and you get that reading
habit then you can start peering into
the periphery about okay well what's
this
you know there's business stubs 0 to 1
Peter Tilly what's what's that about or
Ray Dalio principles like I see that all
the time
men reading starts to feel like less
like a chore but you can also expand
your knowledge by reading stuff that
you're not normally reading yeah no one
goes into the gym and looks at like the
big buff guy in the corner and says ya
gonna what you lift in there mate right
ok I'll put that on my barbell and I'll
have a crack then I I've [ __ ] my [ __ ]
up like yeah that's that's what happens
so again with that like it's common
sense and
start the novel quote the nerve alcohol
about reading read what you love until
you love to read and then David Parral
piggybacked off the back of that year
today with his writing course he's got
going in the moment he says write what
you love until he loved to write mmm and
the same could be done for exercise it
do exercise that you love until you love
to exercise as well like the easiest
training plan is the one that doesn't
feel like you've got to go and train
exactly so okay so we know that we need
to pick books like in terms of topic
wise what do I do next next and if
you're really serious about building the
reader having its it's just like
anything else like you need to set aside
time that you want to dedicate towards
building that habit it's I think you use
the gym analogy all the time and I like
to equate reading to building a strong
you know habit in the gym right like you
don't start bench pressing 315 pounds
overnight right you have to work your
way towards it but at the same time you
don't do chest exercises seven days in a
row right you need to have some sort of
balance when it comes to your reading
habit so a lot of people that are asking
for book recommendations a lot of time I
just tell them hey be open about
exploring new topics that you're not
normally accustomed to and here's an
example for me so I obviously read a lot
of personal development self-help
business type books and a couple months
ago at my sister's wedding my uncle who
had no idea I was running this page I
told him I was like hey hey Frank good I
would like you to know that I run a
semi-successful book page on Instagram
you know a couple drinks in but spelling
my and my confidence there and he's like
okay I got a couple book recommendations
for you
and these two books could not have been
farther off the beaten path from the
[ __ ] that I usually read one of them was
that the this Zen art of motorcycle
maintenance all right it's one of those
legendary I don't even know how to begin
to describe that type of book but I
remember just reading the book and to to
the point about getting into the book
early I was so just dumbfounded at what
the [ __ ] this book was about it I had no
idea what was about but I couldn't stop
reading it yeah right so I think it's
it's super important to time in and time
out to just expose yourself to stuff
that you're not
to reading because that will spark some
interest in again that periphery you're
like huh that actually is interesting I
don't know why I would I would come
across metaphysics and the reason of
meaning you know and you can get lost in
chapters and chapters and in that book
about what is meaning what is the
definition of meaning I've never thought
about that in my 32 years but that did
spark a little bit of curiosity and I
would not have come across that question
if I was not open to taking a
recommendation from someone and just
just to open up my perspective a little
bit what was the second book the second
book was called Thunder at Twilight I
forget the name of the author but it was
a historical work based off of Vienna
pre World War one so it's a lot to do
with Austrian politics Austrian economy
there's a lot of historical features you
know if you're familiar with with
Austria in Vienna pre-world War one I'm
sure Chris you're very up-to-date on on
that specific yeah Thomas otherworld
that's literally my wheelhouse man I go
sometimes I wake up in the morning and
just stop thinking about it yeah and and
that's that's one of those books where
the writing completely lost me like I I
was not into it and there's a lot of
historical references a lot of
geological references right like certain
areas of Austria that they're just
riveting off like you're in a
conversation with somebody new and I'm
like what what am i what am I doing here
like what am i reading but to my earlier
point as to why I actually read it there
was a lot of social pressure s why I
forced myself to finish it because I was
a part in part of a book club with with
my sister and my dad and my uncle who
actually recommended that book so I felt
a lot of pressure to finish this book
because if I didn't they'd be like dude
they'll like I just recommend in this
book and you didn't even read it [ __ ]
so there are some times when I do
succumb to social pressure in terms of
finishing a book even though I hate it
yeah I understand completely so we need
to set time aside for it how my
suggestion I don't know how you do it
but as someone again who's I'm total
noob - as far as sort of the reading
journey goes but my best way is part of
the morning
but in the morning routine set timer for
20 minutes read for 20 minutes and yep
because I like to go back over stuff
quite a lot I'm concerned about
retention yep that can sometimes maybe
even only be like 15 pages and then
sometimes it may be more like like
fiction or something it might be 30
gradually turns it tends to not be
fiction on the morning another habit as
well another suggestion for people is to
read nonfiction by day and read fiction
by night I tend to find that or not
necessarily fiction but like nonfiction
story or biographies by night basically
not personal development by night you
know if you're trying to really get your
mind going about how to upgrade your
personal finances or this psychological
strategy for building a business or
working on yourself
sending yourself to sleep with that to
me doesn't always put me in the quite
quite the right sort of mood whereas if
I'm just imagining this world or this
story or this journal of something
that's going on that can't make a bit of
a difference yeah and I've heard similar
talk tracks about combining both
audiobooks in physical books in the same
manner right like you use physical books
for self-help business and personal
development and you use audio books for
one of those biographies memoirs fiction
things that are easier to digest right
and at the end of the day it's whatever
works best for you there's no one right
way to consume books whether if it's
audiobooks or reading at night reading
in the morning as long as you were doing
it you're gonna see some benefit from it
how do we retain what we read it's a
good question and I think that's one of
the biggest challenges that I often have
too and I make some references to this
and in my might get better with books
page and I kind of joke at it that
retaining books is very challenging
right like so often it you come across a
book that you're like damn that was
awesome I love that book and then two
weeks later someone's like hey Jim like
how's that book and you're like um so
you know it was good
there's a guy does he it's good I
recommend it do ya
so I mean it's natural that it happens
to everyone right to people who don't
admit it it's it's very challenging to
retain the stuff that you read that
being said you do have to be very
proactive about making sure there are
key concepts that you you want to keep
with you in the process that I go
through it's it's just three simple
steps number one is I always read with a
pencil or a highlighter some sort of
writing apparatus with me so every
single time I come across something that
that makes me pause that makes me go
home or you know that's interesting let
me let me expand on that something that
just tongues on that tugs on that string
of curiosity underline it write it down
and make sure I fold a page down on the
corner so at the end of each chapter or
at the end of the book and it kind of
depends on the book you know how I want
to parse that out but I always go back
to the important parts every single time
I finish a book right make sure that I'm
taking the time to digest the important
parts so I can retain that right that's
the little that's the whole goal here so
if I can take everything that I
underlined or jot it down I either put
it in a notebook or use note cards right
so I'll take maybe a stack of like three
or four note cards yeah and I did this
for ego is the enemy by Ryan holiday and
I have them right on the corner my
willing windowsill over there and I try
to read them at least once a week and
that's that's the important part is you
underline everything you write it down
in some sort of notebook or note card
but I think the most important thing is
you have to revisit them constantly
right there's no way that you're gonna
remember something if you don't
constantly remind yourself of the
importance of it so for me personally
what I do is I keep those stack of note
cards and a once or twice a week if I
have a little free time I'll just like
to cycle through them I reread them that
is interesting I need to focus more on
that or yeah you know based off of what
I know now maybe that's not it was
important I thought maybe I'll put it in
the back of the pile but it's it's very
important to constantly keep it top of
mind it's an interesting analog approach
that you've got so books is in or read
wise or book Lee or you know any of
these different apps that either
integrate with an iOS reading app that
integrate with Kindle that integrate
with the paperwhite that allow you to
export your highlights automatically and
then they'll email them to you every day
and all this sort of stuff
is not just a disposition of yours that
you've preferred to go analog rather
than digital with both the books you get
and the way that you do your
highlighting yeah it's just my
preference and I think a lot of that has
to do with the physical aspect of
writing it down just helps to ingrain
those messages that much more right if
I'm just simply highlighting something
on a Kindle and I don't use a Kindle at
all and most most of my book reading is
easier through audiobook or physical
book right so if I can physically
underline something if I can physically
write it down and and go through that
process I think it helps ingrian that
message that much more as opposed to
just doing everything digitally yeah
your retention or the way that you find
audiobooks versus normal books reading
no did you stick to what you said before
where you've got more story narrative
style stuff on audio and more depth
personal development stuff on book yes
that's it I have to say like having
developed a reading habit worked real
hard to develop whatever semblance of a
reading habit I've got over the last the
sort of three to four years my retention
from reading something physically versus
listening to it isn't even in the same
universe Brett yeah and I think a lot of
that has to do with with having more of
an active versa passive approach to the
reading process itself right if you're
just listening to an audiobook and maybe
you're doing some chores you're doing
some yard work or something like that
it's really passive but if you are
reading a physical book and again this
is just this is my personal preference
there's no one right way to do this but
me personally having to be proactive
about what I pick and choose to put in
my book and being proactive to
physically pick up these note cards I
think just being more active in that
process helps to retain at least in my
opinion I think as well we need to so
much of this is individual right there
might be someone listening you've got
perfect retention of what they consume
on audio and I have fantastic retention
why consume through podcasts I can tell
you like the type of fire hydrant
outside of Crystal Leah's house like you
know all the total useless information
which I what kind of fire hydrant was it
it's a silver one because he lives in
Beverly Hills Empire Hills you get
silver fire hydrants someday someday
we'll have areas so you know just like
random stuff and it's like I can picked
up through podcasts yeah audiobooks
retentions a little bit less I feel less
involved as less energy going on it
might in my opinion but if I'm not so
bothered about retention and it's more
than overall feel and again that relates
to the type of book right if there's a
core lesson which is the whole book
trying to give it to you with a number
of different stories you're perhaps an
audio book would be great for that
whereas if it's like you know if it's
the 10 things you need to do to complete
your ex
yeah you're only gonna get like maybe
one or two if that's not the style that
you learn in yeah exactly and you do a
good job at reminding people that there
is no one right way to do it but also to
the point that certain books out there
are just so much harder to retain right
like if you've if you've read Robert
Greene's 48 laws of power right there's
so many different laws and a lot of them
are contradictory you're like yeah yeah
la 13 you told me with something else
and law 17 it's completely different so
I think it's important to distill what
type of book it is but also at the same
time just just cut yourself some slack
you're not gonna remember it if I'll
tell you what is a terrible audiobook to
listen to Thinking Fast and Slow that's
it's a challenging read if you actually
sit down and read it too it's
challenging regardless how you consume
it yeah the weight because there's so
many mental exercises and it's like look
at these this list of letters on either
side of the page anything listening to
it and you like and someone told me
someone had said bro you don't you don't
want to try and listen to that book and
I was like no [ __ ] you it's 20 hours
plus like I'm listening to this I'm not
really doing it and then sure enough of
an hour into it knows I don't know
what's going on I don't know who anybody
is I think he got married to her like I
don't know so okay okay right we're into
the meat of it this is what everybody
came for so let's say I'm getting into
reading personal development what what
gets me through the door what's the
entrance ticket into the world of
personal development where do I start
I think the first book that I always
recommend people as atomic habits by
James clear for a lot of reasons right
it's it's one of those books that's easy
to read it's not convoluted in in the
messaging but also the language to
convey the lessons but there's
actionable insights right I gave a lot
of how I see a book based off of how
easy it is to consume but also how easy
it was is how easy it is to implement
right anatomic habits is just an A+ in
both of those regards I mean it's
something and I was actually just
thinking about this day because a little
plug for get better with books I'm
building out a YouTube account my first
video that I'm planning right now is all
about the five life-changing books that
I've come across and atomic habits was
one of them and one of the key
components that I always remind myself
about it
Cabot's is having an identity based
habit system and yeah I mean you see
you're nodding your head because this is
something that's if you're in that
personal development sphere it's it's
something you take very serious right
like if you want to build a better
reading habit rather than just being
like I need to do this and this to
become a better reader rather than doing
that you should just focus on seeing
yourself as a reader identifying
yourself as a reader but then also
taking it one step further and thinking
what would a reader do right so almost
reverse engineering that habit by
identifying yourself as someone who's
already had that and then going forward
with small little wins right and that's
just a quick snippet of atomic habits
and it's just one of those books that
every single person I've come across as
has come back universally saying this
this was a [ __ ] awesome awesome book
oh thank you for recommending yes the
fact that it's so new
does it disservice I think
in a way Little India The Linde argument
that you should be reading books that
are the classics met and the that is the
antidote to the fact that there is a lot
of self-development books that come out
all the time and you need to be careful
in what you would invest your time in
but obviously that puts new classics on
the backfoot and atomic having atomic
calories can be read in in twenty thirty
years time a hundred yeah yep yep so
that's always near the top of the list
for me and that to add on top of that in
terms of easy takeaways the number two
book that I always recommend its it is a
classic back to that how long has this
book been available for Dale Carnegie's
how to win friends and influence people
so this is a staple and that self
development personal self-help regiment
right if you will that books been around
for close to 100 years now and it is
still on the top of the bestsellers list
because of how again easy it is to
digest and how easy it is to implement
into your daily life and how it came
across this book was an interesting
story so I just graduated college it was
you know gosh almost eight nine years
ago had no idea what I was doing with my
future right like it's just aimlessly
wandering around my my early 20 year old
existence right and I was puttering
around at my house and I was walking
through my dad's old office he used to
run his own business from the basement
of my parents house so when he moved out
he left all of his books there so I was
just going through some of his old books
I came across this book how to win
friends and influence people and I was
like ah that sounds interesting right I
just based a book by its cover
quite literally there so I picked it up
I read it and probably a couple days
time and it really changed my
perspective mainly on how you
communicate with people number one but
number two having the perspective to see
how your message is perceived by the
other person's eyes right if you can
communicate with someone and not be all
about me me me me but rather look from
their perspective as to why would this
person even want to talk to me well most
likely they want to talk about
themselves right people are inherently
selfish and that they want to talk about
themselves right that's just the nature
of people so if you can use that to your
advantage one of the key adages that I
always use from from how to
when friends and influence people is to
be interesting be interested
so if you were talking to someone and
you can genuinely be interested in what
they're saying and you say hey tell me a
little bit more about that well that's
that's fascinating how is that how is
that impacting your life and really just
having that perspective of how is this
conversation beneficial to that person
people will come away from that
conversation being like holy [ __ ]
Jim is a great conversationalist even
though that person just talked 45
minutes about themselves yeah I can't
remember the book that this is in oh
this is gonna kill me you might be able
to tell me there was a study done why
they put a guy on a plane and they said
we need you to sit I need to speak to
the person next to you for the entire
flight in it's like an eight hour flight
I don't let them you don't they're not
allowed to look at the screen they're
not allowed to look out that like just
get their attention
yeah you're not allowed to tell them
anything about you not even your name
yeah not allowed to tell them anything
about you in any way we got off and they
do a little survey afterwards and
they're going up to all of the
passengers but it's this particular guy
that they're looking for they get di
person he was speaking to and they say
hello so we're just gonna around today
just doing a little bit of a survey just
way to ask how your flight was and who
you were sat next to and what'd you talk
about he said ah I'll start next this
amazing guy who's such a phenomenal guy
now you know it's just we were passing
conversation so that's pretty would you
be able to tell us his name other guys
like no and you that that just drills at
home right you know people you have
people like to talk about themselves and
I think is well like it's not often that
people are interested like this is a
catastrophe that plays off the back of
something which is real pervasive then
you don't often get people that are
interested so when you do you're like oh
yeah I'm sure I get to I can open myself
up and I can talk about they're not
staring at their phone while I can play
with ideas that's okay
how it win friends and influence people
atomic habits why are we going next
third it's a combination of two because
there's there's really two modes of
thought here one is if you want to go
down a motivational route book can't
hurt me by David Goggins is just one of
those books that just kicks you
right that's dude if you've heard him on
the Joe Rogan podcast or if you've heard
his audiobook like he is just that wrong
[ __ ] that's you know [ __ ] you
listening to this guy and you're like
you you don't even realize but your
fists are clenched and you're like your
jaws clenched and you're like yeah yeah
like you're about to rip off some flesh
where you be a teeth but that's just one
of those motivational books where you
listen to someone's story and you can
really understand how for the human
potential can take and just based off of
your own mental limitations right so if
you can distill someone's personal
journey just based off of pushing those
boundaries it starts to open up your
eyes as to you know maybe I'm being a
little bit of [ __ ] and this this area
of my life or you know maybe I gave up a
little bit easier there so it's it's
those types of motivational stories that
I actually made a post about in my
Instagram yesterday about Goggins has
this unique capability of calling out
your [ __ ] while I'm motivating you
at the same time and I think it's those
types of books that keep you accountable
to look yourself in the mirror like he
uses the accountability mirror right he
emphasizes that just making sure that
you're doing everything that you can day
in and day out to push that potential
but the second book and this is a little
bit away from from that motivational is
to Cal Newport like you were saying
about digital minimalism one of my
favorite books especially right now
given the state of the world say to the
event says deep work and if you are a
creative if you are an entrepreneur if
you are doing anything where you want
your work to speak for itself I think
it's never been more important than it
is right now to set aside some time
where you are uninterrupted where you
can take long periods of time to focus
on your work at hand and I think Cal
Newport does a great job at outlining
wide deep work given the state of events
right now is one of the most important
skills that you can you can work on it's
a it's a term all of its own though
right you know yet let people talk about
doing deep work right and it's a
reference to him I couldn't agree more
it's an antithesis is the it's the
antidote to the always on million
project million tabs open at once
catastrophe that we find ourselves in
okay so we've got we've got
Foundation for self-development this is
we're in we're in the door now and why
don't we do some books that you think
people may not have either heard of or
not read some undiscovered gems still
staying in at the self-development space
and then we'll go into more like a
biography and then maybe a figure a
couple of fictions as well sure so if we
want to start with a book that's a
little bit under the radar that is
equally as important when it comes to
personal development self-help is a book
by James Allen called as a man thinketh
it's a very simple read I think it's
it's no more than 150 pages but the
basis of that is it's very similar to
Napoleon's Hill you know concept about
thinking good thoughts and making sure
that you're proactive about the way that
you're thinking right using thinking as
a model for success and it's similar to
to Marcus Aurelius right when he says
control your thoughts control your life
the basis of this book as a man thinketh
is just being very proactive about your
thoughts as an entity right so if you go
about your day being very pessimistic
very cautious you know being over all
doom and gloom right like that's gonna
manifest itself in in your actions and
the way that you pursue your your
ambitions in life but if your overall
optimistic if your overall energetic and
if you believe in yourself if you tell
yourself and you constantly remind
yourself that you're capable of doing
powerful things and this is just based
off of having that initial thought
process that you can it's just something
that you can constantly use to cultivate
a lot of that positive energy in your
life and I think one of the key
takeaways and the key quotes that I got
from that is he compares your mind to a
garden right and if you're constantly
cultivating your mind in a way that
you're cultivating a lot of good
thoughts it's going it's going to yield
a lot of positive things right it's
going to yield a bountiful fruit or
vegetables things that's going to be
nourishing to your life whereas if
you're if you're neglecting your
thoughts if you're neglecting your mind
similar to a garden it's going to yield
a lot of weeds a lot of things that are
gonna clutter your vision right so I
think it's very important to be very
proactive about how you think because
that in self minute that's in into your
life yeah and also not a very nice place
to be no
the garden as I as my garden youth four
years old now it took I got flower wall
and everything but um yeah ten to ten to
your garden what's next what else we got
none let's go nothing so I've under
under known underrated self development
I'm actually an interesting book that
you may know well aware of as a economy
the truth by a dizzy injury yeah have
you got the second version have you got
the new yeah I haven't got the the new
version yeah he's what you doing Ron he
says it done an expanded an expanded
version I have a couple of copies over
there that literally just now I don't
think he can get it to himself so he's
in Romania and okay like Amazon isn't
delivering his own book to him so come
on he sent it to me and he was like yo
broke he just hope I would go through
and see if there's any printing errors
and stuff like that but he's so
hilarious no worries
but yeah economy of truth by busy tell
us tell us why yeah yeah so it's it's
another one of those books and we were
talking about this earlier in the
conversation about distilling wisdom
into that bite-size manageable format
and content and I think visi is someone
who I interacted mainly off of my
Instagram page that he hit me up I had
actually been following him on my
personal account for for almost a year
before I started my page and he had
reached out to me so I was almost a
little like starstruck I'm like [ __ ]
busy reaching out to me I made it but
it's just one of those books that's it's
just parsed down wisdom it's it covers
everything from from philosophy and just
just daily personal development it's
just one of those books that's easy to
consume but at the same time gets you to
think and I think at the end of the day
if you can read a book that actually
creates an opportunity to pause and
think I think you're onto something good
there it's a unique type of book it's
thought aphorisms you could pick it up
and put it down in a page well as long
as you gave yourself three or four
minutes to think about what was on that
page and how it relates to your life
it's a very unique way of reading and as
we mentioned earlier on much more active
you know okay let's get into perhaps
some more not necessarily personal
development but still nonfiction just
some either some favorites some unknown
ones whatever you think yeah so there's
there's a recent trend that I've been
encountering it's the the memoir type of
book where it's it's an individual who
is not writing about their whole
life story but more so just like a very
specific focus and experience that
happened to of course their life and one
of the books that I just encountered a
memoir style was educated by Tara West
over it was a phenomenal story and it
was just based off of this this girl who
grew up in [ __ ] Idaho right this was
this was a recent story true story - she
was part of a family that was deep
really religious but also fiercely
separatist so her father was one of
those guys that says you know school is
the devil school the government
Illuminati like distrust everything so
she came from a family that was very
rarely home school no no formal
education but she got to a point in her
adolescence where she said you know I
want to go to school and the book was
all about her trajectory from basically
being having no education to getting
into BYU getting honors going to grad
school getting her doctorate from
Harvard University and this transition
from having no education to having the
most education some of the key tenants
there are all about your identity right
like who how do you see yourself
throughout the course your transition
your adolescence in theory quest for
life and for her you know her family
always harped on having an education as
something that was you know
untrustworthy right like oh you're one
of them you're one of those educated
folks and it's one of those books where
you have this identity of who who you
think you are and how you see yourself
but also in relation to your closest you
know friends and family right so how
does my family perceive me how does that
affect how I see myself but it's also
about just having the confidence in your
own identity to say hey this may piss
people off this may rub people the wrong
way but I have enough convictions in
myself that this is who I truly am
regardless of the consequences so I
can't recommend that one enough it's one
of those those page-turners where you
come across an author who's just a
fantastic writer and storyteller so
educated tara Westover highly recommend
it amazing what's nice shoe dog fur for
those who have followed my page and
obviously I do a lot of personal
development you know business type books
but shoe dog falls into one of those
books that is just one of an absolute
page turners so if anyone who has not
read
shoo dog it's a personal memoir by phil
knight who was the founder of a little
company called nike right and it goes
through his his upbringing from how he
was a a local track star in Oregon to
how he started this fledgling company
into a multi-billion dollar enterprise
right and that that itself is an
interesting story but if we talk about
what makes a book interesting and what
really gravitates you it's it's that
writing style and Phil Knight has one of
those unique writing styles where it's
it's almost like it's like a vapor it's
like he's going off in every single
direction but it's so eloquent in the
essence where you can get what he's
saying but there's so much style and
charisma tap to the way that he writes
so shoe dog definitely add that one to
your list he'll I love it and then one
that might be a little bit less
well-known from that similar sort of
genre before we do a bit fiction yeah
one thing that I would also add to that
list it's it's another recent book
similar to that vein about business and
personal memoirs was the ride of a
lifetime by Bob Iger who was actually
just recently stepped down as the CEO
and chairman of Disney right so one of
these business Titans that talks a lot
about his upbringing and this is an
interesting point when you read a lot of
these these business and memoir type
books you see a lot of commonalities you
see a lot of similarities between these
people who have so much success and a
right of a lifetime is one of those
books where these guys just have an
insatiable work ethic they have the
confidence they have the vision but they
also have the wherewithal when they come
across failures and they come across
life just just kicking them down a peg
having a lot of confidence in yourself
to drug dust yourself off and keep going
so ride of a lifetime Bob Iger rise of
Disney as a company definitely a great
read - that's sick
and now finishing up a couple of fiction
books we've got a daytime read so it
would maybe get a couple of nighttime
reads as well what are some some fiction
books that you were read recently that
you've enjoyed so there's there's one
fiction book that I will always
recommend and this one was given to me
by an old colleague of mine was a book
called watership down I'm not sure if
you're familiar with that it's it's it's
a story about rabbits okay right so it's
oh yeah so it's
it's a book about how a flock of rabbits
was displaced due to deforestation and
their trek across unchartered land right
and you're thinking okay a book about
rabbits how is that relevant but I think
it talks a lot about key tenants of
camaraderie shared mission courage right
a lot of these key tenants of virtues
that you'd like to see in the hero's
journey right and it's seeing its
unveiled in these cute cuddly rabbits
and and the constant threat of predators
like foxes and and great great horned
owls right the things that you don't see
as a predator but if we look in the
perspective of a rabbit I think holy
[ __ ] you know life is a wrap it's pretty
hard these days but it's just one of
those it's again one of those stories
that's very easy to follow along but at
the same time like you get some some
inspiration and personal reflection from
from reading about rabbits I like the
idea of using fiction as a way to learn
lessons that yes that some personal
development books can't teach us I was
the example about 1984 that it taught me
more about appreciating the power of my
thoughts than pretty much any other
self-development book could have done
because it's delivered in this like this
Erik allegory allegory cool weird sort
of symbolic way you know it's a it's an
odd one but look man Jim it has been so
fun
I implore everybody to go and check out
at get better with books on that's it
Instagram Wednesday you just say are not
gonna be live when and is that get back
with books as well that's also get
better with books yeah I got my
microphone being shipped from amazon.com
this weekend so I plan on filming
editing and posting my first video this
weekend I'm sorry after that so it will
be in the show notes below anything else
that you want to plug any other things
people should go and check out of yours
now that's it right now I just just got
the Instagram handle get the YouTube
coming out so working on and just keep
creating good content and I appreciate
everybody for the time and the attention
bro it's it's an absolute pleasure you
need to go and check this out I also
have to give a shout out to how patient
you are to align books perfectly
straight like the ability to put books
in completely neat lines with all the
gaps being exactly the same way is just
you know that's not a little bit of seed
a little bit of OCD but at the same time
got to put good content out there IG is
very competitive so take the time to
post good pics baby yeah I get it man
look Jim thank you so much everyone
that's been listening all of the books
that we've just gone through will be
linked below in the show notes every
single one of them so you think I'm
gonna go check that out all linked in
the show notes below you need to go and
give Jim a follow-up get better with
books but for now thanks man thank you
so much likewise Chris good chat with
you be well
[Music]
you